si vous avez l'impression que beaucoup
d'élections partielles depuis l'arrivée
des libéraux au pouvoir en 2014
bah c'est le cas et ça coûte cher je
ressens depuis le début de l'automne
2016 une fatigue qui ne me quitte pas
l'élection partielle d'envoi le 29 mai à
montréal devient la 14e partiel au
québec depuis la dernière élection
générale 7 avril 2014 bien orane 15e
très bientôt dans la circonscription de
louis hébert à québec je crois
humblement vous redonner une voix
représentée dignement et au meilleur de
mes capacités mais construit ça vient
égaliser le record connue pendant le
mandat du parti québécois sous rené
lévesque entre 1981 et 1985 reconnu les
faits réussi à faire élire son
gouvernement en avril 80 à chaque
élection partielle coûte en moyenne 550
mille dollars selon le directeur général
des élections du québec
alors si on tient compte de toutes les
partiels passé est prévu pour le présent
mandat libéral
les québécois vont avoir dépensé plus de
8 millions de dollars bien des départs
donc et la facture aurait pu être
beaucoup plus importante
le gouvernement a aboli en 2015 les
indemnités de départ pour les députés
qui démissionnent de façon hâtive
[Musique]